I became involved with conservation work
and through that dr. Wilson's
biodiversity foundation which I am on
the board of because it was clear to me
that that mankind human activity was
degrading our earth's resources at an
alarmingly rapid rate and that we were
losing species right and left important
species perhaps in some cases we knew in
other cases we hadn't yet full knowledge
of a species or organism before it was
lost it's my understanding that that
much of much of our medicine much of our
food stuff that may be required in the
future will come from these reserves of
biodiversity which are rapidly
disappearing and unless we have fully
protected
bio systems we will not will lose the
potential to learn how nature works in
some very specific cases and that nature
that information may be critical in our
understanding of how to manipulate what
is in our power to manipulate to to save
biodiversity save the power of our
planet to sustain life
the work itself has is as dr. Wilson has
said is an educational effort to cause
people to understand and to protect
these reservoirs of biodiversity I
haven't so much changed my mind about
how how to accomplish these things it is
really the mission of dr. Wilson's
foundation to bring understanding to the
broad population and young people who
will be making important decisions in
the future and to current leaders both
in the business community and in
government who can make policies which
are more beneficial to the preservation
of biodiversity so I can't say
specifically that that that his way of
approaching biodiversity has changed the
way I think about it
except to say but dr. Wilson has a great
gift for language and he has made it a
very powerful he's made a very powerful
argument in favour of of living nature
and and I find his argument his
persuasive powers have
have led me to think about ways of
presenting the problem to other people
I make myself available for to do on
camera
public service announcements and
whatever I can do it and I've been
approached I was approached by the State
Department which is responsible for
animal trafficking in wild animal parts
and wild animals
to do a PSA a series of PSAs which I was
very happy to do so that that's just
important it's part of my commitment to
the to the work of conservation
that's a very difficult question and I
don't know that I have an answer for it
I think the basis of of acting is
empathy I've always thought that knowing
how other people feel and certainly one
of the one of the important judgments
you can make about a person is how they
fit into their environment into the
world that they live in specifically
whether they're a positive force or a
negative force I've always loved the the
quiet and the solace of nature I've been
fascinated by the complication of nature
and in a way I found I found that
although I was raised without a formal
religion that I have I've found a a
ethical reality in nature and the
preservation of it and I think that
informs
me in every way
well I think the answer is that we can't
live well without living grain we've
come to the point where we have we have
stretched our resources to the to the
point of failure we we haven't seen it
coming with such with enough time and so
now it has reached the stage where we
where we're recognizing it that we are
in crisis that the effects of global
warming the effects of the degradation
of of the see the effects on the on the
future for fresh water all of those are
very serious problems which are begging
for a solution if we are not able to
commit the resources and the energy and
the and the wisdom that we do have to
solving these problems will likely
disappear and the world will be a better
place for it the world will continue
without human beings it's it's not a
problem but to ensure a future for human
beings human for human beings we've got
to make better use of our resources and
manage
a more sustainable lifestyle
is a fictional character
I can't really think of him as an
environmental hero or or anything
outside of the context of them of the
films in which he in which he lives I
think that's the answer
we think about my working in acting as
I don't I don't have an ambition for
particular roles I have an ambition to
do good work with good people tell
stories that are compelling and
emotional and to engage my own ambitions
to do good work that's my that's my goal
for my professional life
the only advice I've ever offered young
actors is is to try and figure out how
to do it for yourself never be caught
with the with the idea that that you can
imitate someone else's success as much
as you might admire what someone else
does
don't try and imitate that find your own
way and find what find your own voice
find your own feelings and that will
make will give you a unique opportunity
mentors were teachers and Scout masters
and I think it had a lot to do with my
it had a lot to do with my sense of the
importance of nature it had a lot to do
with my my sense of what a true and just
and useful man is and it's pretty
fundamental basic human kindness
expressed in a variety of different ways
and my professional mentors are well
known they are they are the wonderful
directors that I've had the good luck to
work with Spielberg and Lucas and and
Sydney Pollack and Alan Pakula and and
others who have been very important to
my professional life and to my personal
life